convinced every sane woman in the city
is taping so [ __ ] dramatic you
telling you he's women our psycho oh my
god they can't all be that bad I don't
know maybe I'm the only person in the
world who hates small talk
dude everyone hates small talk so what
really why do I feel like my head is
gonna explode in a hurricane of generic
questions where are you from where do
you work where did you go to school you
know the DMI better than you questions
yeah well asking this is how you know
you're a New Yorker how much do you pay
for your apartment how many square feet
what was your broker's fee I think this
place is owned by the same guy that owns
Balthazar do you ever take a date there
it's not that bad I think it is that bad
oh [ __ ] oh yeah complete parties will
not be easy okay Charlie you know what
I'm your friend I love you we all love
you but do you know what your problem is
you excuse me excuse you well you're
certainly not the first guy to think
he's some big deal for getting a lot of
dates in this town that doesn't mean you
have any idea what you're doing when
you're out with these women thank you
look any guy with an American Express
card and a pulse and got a Danish like
half a million more single women than
men it's just that when you're out on
these dates it takes two to tango that's
all I'm saying I am starving should I
check what the hostess is just face it
okay we're never getting it and here's a
new thought for you I am NOT the problem
you know I don't even know why I try way
to be introspective way to view of mind
I don't even know why I'd expect
anything else yeah you're completely
wrong I cannot even believe you think
that you know what whatever
I'm gonna go talk to the hostess
beyond that though you got